bonjour Aline
bonjour madame
Muriel Robin bonjour Muriel
[Musique]
Amélie Nothomb
mais c'est dingue le monde qui a ici
Madame Simone aujourd'hui c'est
l'anniversaire de Dave bisous à Dave
c'est l'anniversaire de Gérard Jugnot
bisous à Gérard Jugnot et c'est
l'anniversaire de Rocco Siffredi
[Applaudissements]
je ne connais pas je n'ai jamais vu
aucun de ces films slip ou quels sont un
slip bien sûr parce que parce que on a
une vie qui peut pas qui peut pas se
conjuguer avec des choses pas pratiques
tout ça oh non slip 100% malgré le
Douglas a aussi eu des ennuis de santé
un cancer de la gorge très avancé en
2010 il a perdu plus de 15 kilos puis il
a annoncé qu'il était guéri un peu plus
tard il a précisé qu'il avait un peu
menti en réalité ce n'était pas un
cancer de la gorge mais un cancer de la
langue du à ses pratiques sexuelles
c'est lui qui l'a expliqué il n'a jamais
caché qu'il était addict au sexe
pour vous les gens qui portent des slips
seraient plus macho ceux qui portent des
caleçons est-ce que ce serait une oui
sur le côté un peu plus maintenant et un
peu moins artiste puisque je suis une
sorte d'artiste je porte des caleçons et
je défends les caleçons moi je serai
ministre de l'Intérieur j'aurais
supprimé depuis longtemps le LBD40 dans
la série
je te rappelle on les utilise beaucoup
moins on les utilise
quand même je te rappelle qu'il y a un
manifestant je crois dans l'ouest de la
France qui a perdu un testicule une on
dit oui
[Musique]
le F cousine de la belette où personne
curieuse et rusée Fouine oui il compare
quand même
madame Rousseau un taliban oui le mot
que vous employez viens lui de toute
façon extrêmement violent ensuite Cyril
si vous le permettez parce que c'est
juste ou pas parce que la question c'est
pas la violence on peut pas comparer je
vais vous dire que si je vais vous
donner un exemple ça c'est pour moi les
talibans les aliments ils détestent tout
ce qu'il y avait avant eux donc ils ont
dynamité les Bouddha dans les pays dans
les pays où ils ont pris le pouvoir et
Madame Rousseau elle pense qu'au nom de
la cause écolo on peut s'en prendre à
des œuvres d'art des tableaux de Van
Gogh c'est la même chose
c'est quoi ça c'est un caca
non mais au secours alors si je résume
je suis dans une sorte de cantine avec
un serveur qui ne sert à rien et en plus
il y a un truc comme ça pour les
pourboires je comprends vos
confrontations éditoriales sur des
plateaux avec lui le débat parfait
Eric Zemmour
que vous soyez amis avec quelqu'un qui
pense globalement que l'islam et les
musulmans sont de trop je ne comprends
pas donc je ne comprends pas que vous
soutiez monsieur mélange comment
pouvez-vous être le soutien de Monsieur
Mélenchon qui lui aussi a été condamné
le président de la République est
attendu dans dans quelques minutes ou
dans quelques heures vous allez nous
préciser ça Anthony lebos qui est
certain c'est qu'une nouvelle fois le
président est attendu dans des
circonstances de toute évidence
compliquée pour évoquer la réforme des
lycées professionnels
j'ai une question pour vous dites-moi
qu'est-ce que vous engagez qu'est-ce que
vous envisagez pour l'avenir de la
France vous êtes sûr que vous voulez pas
une photo plutôt du chef de l'État se
suivent et se ressemblent depuis deux
semaines il y a toujours se déplacement
ce comité d'accueil organisé par par les
syndicats on est ici à Saintes communes
de environ 25000 habitants on est sur un
rond-point la moitié de la circulation
est le cœur moitié vous voyez déjà les
casseroles les cuillères les ustensiles
de cuisine qui sont ici il y a
évidemment la CGT et aussi solidaire il
y a aussi même la section locale de la
France insoumise
à présent Paco peut assumer pleinement
sa passion la politique sans risquer les
sarcasmes de ses camarades collection de
cartes de visite d'élus
ce sont des contacts qui peuvent
toujours servir ça c'est des jeunes avec
Macron le mouvement de jeunesse de la
République en marche
[Musique]
j'aimerais vous remercier pour le
confinement des mi-temps on a vécu
énormément de choses pendant ce contenu
moi j'ai bien aimé je pense d'abord
faire une carrière au niveau de la
diplomatie puis ensuite passer à la
politique par exemple en tant que député
des Français pour l'étranger
ceux qui pourraient s'accorder avec la
fonction de diplomate puis membres de la
commission des affaires étrangères
l'Assemblée nationale etc donc les
recrutements sont bloqués là alors en
tout cas dans les aspects administratifs
sur les ressources humaines ils ne
recrute plus qu'ils estiment le patron
d'IBM s'exprimé il estime que 30% de ces
26000 postes administratifs pourraient
être remplacés par l'intelligence
artificielle
à la la qu'est-ce que je vais faire il
faut que je
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que je
continue à faire ce métier donc j'ai
décidé d'essayer d'autres choses j'ai
voulu faire médecin mais j'avais pas
fait assez d'études je voulais faire
policier j'avais fait trop d'études
j'ai voulu devenir religieux mais il y a
beaucoup de trop de contraintes je peux
pas être imam j'aime trop l'alcool je
peux pas être à main j'aime trop le
jambon je peux pas écrire j'aime pas
assez les enfants donc
[Musique]
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis une petite
phrase tout à fait en bas les patrons
peuvent vous mettre une amende si vous
faites du gaspillage
c'est
par ici on est sur un parcours GPS dans
50 mètres vous êtes arrivés et je peux
prendre une amende si je considère ou
jetez un kilo de viande voilà moi en
contrepartie